that performance oh my gosh God that's
why you're winning Awards
cute that's very sweet you're one of the
Great the great Gardens it's like one of
my all-time favorite performances I was
so scared oh my God I literally people I
like like I just I I think I had some
type of break psychotic break yeah you
would have to yeah full commitment real
weird I I was just I didn't because I
didn't think I could do it you know have
you ever felt that way like it's all the
time I don't unpack for the first two
weeks of a shoot because I think I'm
gonna get fired
I'm always convinced seriously yeah
okay I'm like let me just not unpack
because it's so depressing to take
things out of the drawers like so and
then at a certain point I I feel like
they've filmed too much they can't go
back I'm not gonna get fired now I mean
okay Yellow Jackets hello
did you know it was gonna be a total
phenomenon
no I don't I mean I got so used to not
having expectations honestly I really I
try not to but I knew it was so good and
during the first season every script we
got got better and better and I just was
like oh this is really good I think like
I think it's gonna be great and this
show is such a testament to like it just
did get better and better and better
yeah who anyone were devouring this
season
as we all Devour the show yes um they're
gonna eat
is everyone asking you Last of Us
everything because you're in that Mega
head too
[Applause]
lucky evade the question do you just
change the subject what do you do when
everybody wants all the spoilers I well
the last of us now is over so that's
good I it's already happened yeah
there's no spoilers but yeah for Yellow
Jackets I just have to I can't say
anything I'm not allowed yeah
I know I'm gonna give you a spoiler
before the day is through I can feel it
and it has been I mean we did Ever After
now 25 years ago
[Music]
foreign